[Musique]
on est une exposition de 35 à peu près
exposants donc fait différents univers
médiéval fantasy City space et puis il y
a plein de petites créations sur Harry
Potter sur Mario plein de divers milieux
maritime
aussi en général les univers sont assez
mélangés mais
on essaie de regrouper les thèmes
plupart et comme on a des gros audios
comme le médiéval le City ou le Space
bon c'est sûr que ça fait des des zones
un peu plus grand de personnalisé
disons au petit au grand au plus grand
c'est ça de 0 à 200
ans on est une association à peu près de
membres donc tous des fans adultes Lego
et puis on fait différents activités
exposition on fait aussi des ateliers
une fois par mois plein de choses comme
ça et puis est passionné puis on fait
des créations differs et
[Musique]
Verri